here's what would happen if the James  Webb Telescope found alien life  looking for life in outer space well you  wouldn't look for little green aliens  with bug eyes you'd look for Bio  signatures characteristics in a planet's  atmosphere that would be evidence of  life in the past or present you'd need  to detect the presence of an exoplanet  around a distant star using the transit  method as a planet passes in front of a  star you'd observe its light slightly  diminishing you wouldn't go public with  this information right away you'd  probably want to follow NASA's  confidence of Life detection scale  commonly referred to as cold it's a  seven level scale that relies on  collecting data at each level finding  aliens wouldn't be as exciting as it is  in the movies it would probably just be  many announcements each time you  gathered new data rather than a big  world altering declaration so